I'm writing every Devil's fruit in one
piece to figure out which is the best
one this is the gutsugutsunomi the smell
smell fruit which turns your body into a
blast furnace that you can melt Metals
inside it was eaten by Bill the leader
of the silver pirate Alliance now this
melt melt fruit allows you to deal some
serious damage by melting or into a wide
range of weapons or simply by spitting
molts and metal for defense you can code
yourself in hot and hard metal and in
terms of special abilities if you awaken
this fruit you could even melt the
environment around you now in case you
don't remember the smelled food or bill
here that's because it's from the Silver
Mine Villa Arc that only happened in the
anime after dressrosa and sadly those
episodes aren't available on Netflix in
the US but that's not a problem with
expressvpn because it allows you to
change your online location to countries
like Japan where every episode of One
Piece is available along other anime
like jutsukaisen chainsaw man or Demon
Slayer season 3. so just use my link in
the comments to get a free trial